there have been many cases where he's
basically been treated as if he doesn't
exist they used the wrong photo for him
he tweeted out that every other campaign
gets to have people who represent them
on your shows but with him it has to be
him personally so when people on the
Left are starting to realize oh this
isn't about Republican versus Democrat
this is about us versus them and you
could just as easily be a Democrat and
be our them eyes are opening and that is
a very very healthy phenomenon I always
say that the corporate press is the
enemy of the people and I think that's
the moderate position this is the Rubin
report and according to a Russian bot
farm I'm Dave Rubin quick reminder guys
to subscribe to our YouTube channel
which gives you a 5% chance of actually
seeing our videos in the feed pretty
good
joining me today is the author of the
new right the host of the you're welcome
podcast and the man that I've dubbed the
Willy Wonka politics
Michael malice welcome back to the Rubin
report thanks so much
well sir where to start I think your
outfit yeah it reminds me of somebody a
former guest I didn't see you until two
minutes ago you walked in here wearing
this gorgeous little thing yeah I've
been known for this look for years is
that right all of a sudden I get phone
calls who's this woman tulsi who's been
dressing like you she's so nuts she even
put a streak in her hair to pass as me
even more and I looked this up she says
she's from this state called Hawaii
white I never heard this there's a bunch
of volcanoes in the middle of the
Atlantic and we're supposed to believe
that this is a state they live on
volcanoes rain of liquid metal that they
check the weather and this is people
this is how they gerrymander the
electoral college and now they're trying
to say Graham's estate when I asked my
friend where's Graham find me on the map
he points this little island by the boot
that Sicily you saying Graham BAM Graham
have you ever found they're making up
words I'm thinking them states that this
is how the fake news media gets over it
anyway getting back to her campaign I
think she's great
yes I've been following her very closely
and if
it's reprehensible what's being done to
people like tulsi gabbard the
congressman from so-called Hawaii and
all the other Democratic outliers this
is a wonderful change in our politics
where so many people are realizing the
nature of the enemy all right so we're
gonna talk about all of that stuff but
because a huge portion of our people
just listen to audio I do feel that I
have to describe where you're wearing
honky you are in a white Leisure Suit
it's a suit this is a business a leisure
suit it seems like a leisure so you look
like Leisure Suit Larry or you look like
Larry from Three's Company or something
like that or we can do this or Don
Johnson or John Travolta suit but you
are know this is very much the tulsi
gabbard
white zone this is the Michael malleus
look that tells that he'll see
appropriate yes yes yes no okay so you
hit you get a whole bunch of stuff there
the reason that I wanted to have you
back because as you know I find you to
be one of the most interesting political
thinkers out there I do
thank there you go paying you a
compliment right affront you you
consistently strike me as someone that
is always like really on what I would
say is the forward fringe of what's
happening culturally and politically and
the whole shebang so let's let's start
where you just started there that there
suddenly seems to be a couple outliers
with the Dems and the DNC or the powers
that be or the gatekeepers or the New
York Times or CNN or whatever else you
want to call that not too happy yeah
for a long time conservatives often get
things wrong and I criticize them very
heavily on my Twitter and when I speak
of them I do so with great love and
affection they have always argued that
the media is a wing of the DNC and what
we're seeing recently now is it's more
accurate to say that the DNC is a wing
of the media because you'll see things
like anyone who deviates as you
mentioned earlier from basically the
media's party line is crushed let's
let's give an example I'm a Democratic
congressman right let's suppose from
Hawaii or some other or some other but
they barely exist death and for three
years my constituents have heard CNN and
MSNBC talk about Russia collusion Russia
collusion Trump's Hitler Trump's this
drums that how am i as a politician
supposed to go back to Mike and
situates and say with a straight face I
think Trump's the worst president ever
I think he's racist concentration camps
you know despicable he's ruined the
presidency but I don't think this is
grounds for removing him from office and
I don't have that space so it's pretty
clear who's the one who was leading the
charge and who was following it and for
a long time again conservative thought
this was Republican versus Democrat and
now we're seeing that it's establishment
versus outsider because we're seeing it
how they treated Tulsi we're seeing it
how they treated Bernie and Andrew yang
that's the special one because Andrew
yang is hardly some wide-eyed radical
right he's a wonk he's in many ways akin
to Mitt Romney you know in certain ways
he wears the math lapel pin he wants
people to succeed yeah he says he's a
business guy and mostly a centrist right
probably or not probably certainly way
too big government for you right sure
but at least you think he's a sort of
functional human being and doesn't come
out of the mission right and he is there
have been many cases where he's
basically been treated as if he doesn't
exist they used the wrong photo for him
he tweeted out that every other campaign
gets to have people who represent them
on your shows but with him it has to be
him personally so when people on the
Left are starting to realize oh this
isn't about Republican versus Democrat
this is about us versus them and you can
just as easily be a Democrat and B of M
eyes are opening and that is a very very
healthy phenomenon I always say that the
corporate press is the enemy of the
people and I think that's the moderate
position what is the corporate press
really like what is the psychological
makeup of the corporate press that
causes this whole thing sure so
basically what you have are the
universities and that's where the evil
starts and we've been trained since
kindergarten in our government schools
to regard the media as authoritative and
as you know hard-working people fighting
for the little guy and trying to present
the truth yet we see many many examples
of the little guy
Nicholas salmon is a very obvious
example those cadets who were playing
the circle game the gut here's an easy
example the guy who photoshopped CNN
into that gif with Trump wrestling them
CNN said we reserve the right to sue you
yeah that's not to hunt him down destroy
him for creating a meme
it's not looking out for the little guy
that's looking up for number one do you
know I've asked a bunch of guesses but
do you think there's a moment where
something changed because it wasn't
always this hard I get it's being
exposed now more because because we can
all immediately tweet out the truth
the second you know they they pump out
the lie but do you think there was some
other seminal moments somewhere along
the road was it always this horrible and
this is what conservatives don't
appreciate we all learn in high school
about William Randolph Hearst the
spanish-american war remember the Maine
and yellow journalism and then they just
kind of the record scratch and now we're
into today I have a big thread on
Twitter
Walter Durante's at the prime example he
was a New York Times man covering the
Soviet Union and while Stalin
intentionally committed a genocide via
starvation of Ukraine the holiday more
he was putting out dispatches all the
time saying there's no problem if there
is a problem it is malevolent propaganda
he said the Russian people it's a little
tough but they're tightening their belts
tighten their belts is a very
interesting idiom in this context and
what they what Stalin did to these
people is if you were a Kulak which
meant landowner but pretty soon meant
anyone if you had any food in your home
that was for the people they ransacked
her house and took it and if you weren't
starving that's how they knew you were
hiding food and that's who they targeted
so they would beat people mercilessly
they would tear their house upside down
kick him out in the streets you know to
starve and there was another reporter
who and going to this area was forbidden
by the Soviet government there was a
reporter who jumped off the train went
to a few villages reported back what was
happening these Horrors and Durante was
like oh you know he's just an anti
Soviet agitator so this has been going
on for a very long time
they've always been hardcore I call them
jihadis without the testosterone they
have been very demented idea ideology
that will do everything in its power to
maintain its hold on power and only now
that they've been that check in real
time and called out on their tactics in
real time are people realizing oh I'm
just gonna say my point it's not cod
this to yesterday I said it's not about
the corruption it's about the depravity
if it was just hey I'm hiring my brother
and he's getting paid too much money sin
has asked no one would care yeah they
know they do that that's fine
yes this is about amy robach and Jeffrey
Epstein when you have a network that
knows that someone is engaged in the
sexual trade of children and their
concern is not getting an interview with
Meghan Markel and when this is exposed
instead of coming clean it's let's
target the person who revealed this
footage and get them fired at the
network which they went to it's a lot
it's a lot it's a lot but what do you
think that the sort of psychological
condition of these people like when I
watch all of these clips of CNN anchors
saying the reverse of the truth or Cuomo
tweeting out that you know look at the
way the right attacks Greta Thun Berg
when he went after Nick Sandman or just
you know a kid and all of this nonsense
that they never stopped they seemed
completely psychologically unable to
stop and that strikes me is very weird
you know I sit with a lot of people if
you were to say something to me that was
patently true that was against what I
believed I would struggle with it I
would we would work it through I would
ask you some questions but I know myself
I would probably change my mind if you
made a compelling case we now are at a
point where there's a lot of compelling
evidence that these people lie endlessly
and nothing ever stops them I I don't
even know that I would use the word lie
and here's why I talked about this
heavily in the book I regard what I call
the evangelical left these types when
you're a hear n't to a fundamentalist
Creed facts do not change your opinion
in fact contrary facts make that are
down right so if you are talking to
someone who is a hardcore creationist
and you show them fossils they're not
going to wonder if creations was wrong
they will regard this as evidence that
their willpower and faith is correct and
this is just the test and it's the exact
same psychology the contemporary and I
don't regard all leftists in this vein I
regard this specifically as these jihadi
types they have this vision that they
are the ones who are going to save
America in the world and it's a
degeneration of what happened 100 years
ago called the social gospel which was
the premise that instead of an
individual being saved which is a basic
premise of Christianity it's
nation that has to be saved however when
you have this worldview that a nation's
soul can be saved or the earth soul can
be saved that means there is no space
that is outside your purview that means
whatever someone watches whatever
someone does at home anything aspect of
your life is subject to their domination
and control so it is an absolute
totalitarian worldview and they admit it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell